if you couldn't already tell the Hunger
Games had some serious shenanigans on
set in spite of its solemn subject
matter I think it's the funnest set I've
ever been on I've never done this much
cutting up and laughing I'm just focused
too much on the laughter but it seems
that the cast and crew's goofy Nature
Made for a supportive work environment
now fight scenes are an important part
of The Hunger Games so this silly little
cast had to get serious when preparing
for their on-screen combat the actors
had a gym where they could train for
their fight scenes and some of the
actors enjoyed training so much that
they'd get in extra training time
whenever they could spare it on set now
training for fight scenes wasn't just
fun it was important for preventing
onset accidents and injuries
unfortunately it couldn't prevent every
onset injury which is why Jennifer
Lawrence actually went deaf in one ear
while filming